un personnage pour répondre à ces
sessions et évidemment ses cendres
j'en attendais pas
l'ours
oui
10h48 oui c'est bien leur nous sommes en
direct ce matin merci de nous suivre
pour ce qui est le lancement officiel du
second quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
cérémonie d'investiture c'est bien cela
comme cela que ça s'appelle même s'il
s'agit évidemment d'une reconduction
mais celle usage l'usagé républicain qui
veut une nouvelle qu'une nouvelle
cérémonie soit mené bonjour lucile
schmid bonjour merci de m'accompagner
vous êtes vous êtes une essayiste fine
connaisseuse de la politique française
je montre quand même notre votre bouquin
se dire regardez ça vient de sortir chez
bayard emmanuel macron à contretemps
j'espère qu'il sera à l'heure le
président de la république aujourd'hui
on va tout de suite repartir sur sur ces
images qui vont nous accompagner avec
l'arrivée des différentes personnalités
politiques aujourd'hui avant le début de
la cérémonie à 11 heures on va faire un
point je vais tous vous détailler sur le
sur le programme
lucile c'est un moment important c'est
cette cérémonie on a besoin en france de
ces symboles comme ça oui exactement je
trouve que c'est un moment où on perçoit
cette espèce de symbiose tellement
française entre la république et la
monarchie on parle toujours d'un
monarque républicain est à la fois dans
ses symboles de ce tapis rouge qui fait
plusieurs dizaines de mètres hollande
arrive comme vous le voyez à et en plus
alors ça c'est un peu différent
certainement c'est cette idée de la
passation républicaine qui est
représenté par le fait que l'ancien
président de la république qui en plus
on le sait ami emmanuel macron sur
orbite soit là donc je trouve qu'il ya
dans le cérémonial on le voit bien qui
est au cordeau qui est au millimètre on
connaît les horaires à l'avance et aussi
dans tout ce qu'on va voir dans le
déroulement il y aura des moments public
et des moments secret il ya quelque
chose d'extrêmement monarchique moi qui
me frappe à chaque fois que l'on peut
assister comme spectateur à ce moment ce
moment
comment dirais-je qui peut être aussi
assez émouvant où il ya un mélange entre
le personnel et l'institutionnel alors
vous pouvez évidemment réagir sur
youtube sur tweets sur lefigaro.fr je
prends vos questions je transmets tout
ça à lucile j'en vois déjà une tirade
qui n'a pas grand chose à voir mais j'ai
tout de suite fait sous les yeux théo
fournée qui me demandent ce soir une
beau match de coupe de france macron oui
il y sera un peu plus tard on se
concentre sur sur l'investiture alors on
a vu françois hollande on a vu nicolas
on verra nicolas sarkozy arrivé parce
que les deux anciens présidents sont
présents aujourd'hui c'est un symbole
c'est à ces deux anciens présidents qui
ont connu ces moments précis alors
expliquez-moi comment ça se passe
habituellement ses investitures là c'est
un peu particulier parce qu'il ne pas de
passation de pouvoir y a pas de
passation de pouvoir est le fait que
comme vous le dites deux anciens
présidents soient là nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande dont on connaît les
relations extrêmement difficile il faut
se rappeler que en 2012 lorsque françois
hollande
succède à nicolas sarkozy il commet une
sorte d'un père il ne le raccompagne pas
il tourne les talons sur les nicolas
sarkozy est encore en train de descendre
le tapis rouge que déjà françois
hollande at on alors il vous dira plus
tard qu'il le regrette il a dit qu'il le
regrettait mais lorsqu'on regarde les
images l'époque c'est assez frappant de
voir la façon
pas précipité mais en tout cas
extrêmement déterminé avec laquelle
françois hollande tourner les talons
tourner le dos à nicolas sarkozy comme
avec l'idée de tourner la page d'une
époque et qu'aujourd'hui ils soient tous
les deux là pour assister à cette cette
deuxième ce début du deuxième quart
cette investiture à ce début de deuxième
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron qui on le
sait bien a construit son irruption dans
la vie politique française autour du en
même temps du dépassement de la droite
et de la gauche c'est c'est évidemment
puissamment symbolique est certainement
difficile
toujours à digérer je pense pour
françois hollande c'est un espace
guérini à l'image le tron dans marche
devenu renaissance 1 le nouveau nom du
parti des manuels marque roncq on verra
en détaillera la liste des invités
invités importants alors le général
d'armée benoît puga lui c'est le grand
chancelier de la légion d'honneur
important parce que c'est lui qui va
remettre le collier de la légion
d'honneur laurent fabius président du
conseil constitutionnel ça c'est pas
anodin on va on va en parler lui si
depuis richard ferrand président de
l'assemblée gérard larcher président du
sénat le premier ministre ça c'est pour
les officiels mais il ya beaucoup de
monde on va détailler tout ça et on
verra tout ça alors de la sobriété de
l'efficacité c'est ce que nous dit
l'elysée lucide on veut pas en faire des
caisses on sait par exemple que les deux
seules à avoir connu ce genre de
cérémonie sans passation s'est
évidemment mitterrand et chirac sa vait
été très court 25 minutes pour
mitterrand 15 minutes pour chirac là ce
sera visiblement un peu plus long mais
on veut faire ça c'est important
pourquoi on veut faire ça pour montrer
qu'on entre emmanuel macron je veux
entrer montrer qu'il entre tout de suite
dans l'action et que après en fait une
campagne généré presque une non campagne
présidentielle c'est à dire que on sait
bien qu avant le premier tour et mais
elle m'a kron a choisi de laisser une
sorte de vide qu'ils montraient qu'ils
étaient occupés aux affaires du monde
avec la l'irruption de la guerre on y
craint pendant cette campagne avec le
fait qu'il était aussi et il l'est
toujours d'ailleurs président du conseil
de l'union européenne donc on avait le
sentiment que les affaires européennes
et les affaires internationales avaient
fait irruption dans cette non campagne
française est là l'idée de se remettre
tout de suite au travail est importante
je rappelle quand même que par ailleurs
on attend toujours le nom du futur
premier première ministre et que on sent
en tout cas que cette question du rythme
d'entrée dans le deuxième quinquennat
est un sujet qui est toujours sur la
table on suivra les invités parce que
certains certaines personnalités
présentes ya cinq ans était devenu
ministre ensuite donc on scrutera un ces
invités très précisément on vient de
voir arriver gérald harlin vous parliez
de cette actualité européenne cette
guerre en ukraine c'est l'occasion
peut-être pour lui de reprendre ce
statut de commandeur il y aura tout à
l'heure un hommage
un salut aux armées très précisément
juste après la cérémonie d'investiture
ça c'est un rôle qu'il affectionne et
dans lequel la plupart des présidents ne
se retrouvent assez on sait que dans ces
périodes là ces périodes difficiles
c'est là où notamment leur cote de
popularité augmente oui alors elles
augmenté rappelons nous quand même que
lorsque françois hollande décident
d'agir au mali là vous savez aymen
macron a décidé le retrait de la france
du mali le problème de ces actions
militaires il ya deux types de choses on
peut être présent sur la scène
internationale au nom des questions
régaliennes des questions diplomatiques
et puis on peut décider d'intervenir ou
au contraire je rappelons qu'on ne fait
pas la guerre en ukraine que ce qui est
important c'est le soutient évidemment à
volodimir à lens qui le soutient y
compris par l'envoi d'armes un soutien
financier soutien humanitaire soutien
par l'envoi d'armes mais la france n'est
pas en guerre avec la russie donc toute
la question très intéressante et qu
emmanuel macron a très bien joué en
termes de partition c'est de jouer un
rôle d' influence pour restituer le
court pour que le cours du monde se
calme pour que
pour que la paix revienne on voit que
ceci dit face à vladimir poutine c'est
un c'est plutôt un échec pour l'instant
donc rappelons effectivement que c'est
le chef de l'état qui joue ce rôle
essentiel et que là dessus le parlement
le premier ministre ne sont pas non ça
ne sont pas du tout en première ligne
voire sont en permanence des supplétifs
c'est essentiel je voulais quand même
con con détail un petit peu le programme
10h55 à partir de 11h le président de la
république doit arriver dans la salle
des fêtes de l'elysée puis il y aura
ensuite et bien l' annonce officielle la
proclamation des résultats par laurent
fabius c'est intéressant il ya cinq ans
laurent fabius était déjà là il avait
déjà fait un discours oui moi ce qui
m'avait frappé il ya cinq ans et que
vous savez la règle c'est que le
président du conseil constitutionnel est
une sorte de comptable en fait des
résultats c'est à dire qu il explique
que le conseil constitutionnel en fait à
vérifier les votes et il donne les
pourcentages à et pardon il donne le
nombre de votes pardon de voix
en termes absolus qu'ont obtenues
en l'occurrence emmanuel macron et
marine le pen et puis déclare
officiellement le président de la
république élu et en 2017 laurent fabius
avait été bien au-delà de ce rôle de
comptable des voix de comptables
juridiques il avait prononcé un discours
politique et il avait notamment dit en
regardant emmanuel macron droit dans les
yeux que la campagne avait été inédite
et qu'elle avait été une campagne
chamboule tout et il l'avait il y avait
dit combien de ce fait les espoirs qui
reposait sur lui il devrait y répondre
et donc il avait en quelque sorte
représentait une somme j'allais dire une
autorité morale politique bien au delà
du comptable il avait incarné cette
forme de cour suprême constitutionnelle
dont on dit souvent qu'en france on est
démuni puisque le conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas là la puissance
par exemple de la cour suprême
américaine nous sommes donc ça y est
dans la salle des fêtes de l'elysée où
les invités sont sont présents 450
invités 450 501 on nous dit c'est un peu
plus que d'habitude 300 corps constitués
alors c'est vrai que c'est très précis
le syli peau les membres du conseil
constitutionnel
les représentants de l'assemblée du
sénat du conseil économique et social de
la cour des comptes de la cour de
cassation les représentants des ordres
comment la légion d'honneur les
autorités militaires et religieuses qui
ont été invités le syndicat les
syndicats le patronat des prix nobel
aussi hein et puis et puis des invités
personnels et on suivra évidemment c'est
deux présidents à on scrutera les deux
anciens présidents sachez aussi qu'il ya
des collégiens qui seront premier rang
de ceux de ce discours la jeunesse ça
c'est important emmanuel macron va
devoir parler que va-t-il pouvoir dire
ça c'est important parce que c'est
peut-être la première fois qu'il va
pouvoir impulser une dynamique dans son
quinquennat que va-t-il faire à ce qu'il
fera par exemple une allusion subtile on
imagine à la gauche qui a réussi à se
réunir certainement en tout cas lorsque
vous écoutez les différents discours qui
ont été tenus par les président de la
république sous la vème ce qui est
frappant c'est que il ya une sorte
d'obligation qui est de dire qu'on va
réunir les français vous savez donc
c'est un duel de second tour et on gagne
le duel de second tour lorsqu'on est élu
président de la république et tout
l'enjeu s'est brusquement subitement et
et pour le quinquennat de dire qu'on
représente l'ensemble de la société du
peuple français et sa
il ya une manière de le dire qui est
différente selon chaque personnalité est
aussi selon le contexte on sait que le
contexte dans lequel emmanuel macron a
été élu est un contexte assez dramatique
puisque marine le pen a dépassé les 40%
et que devant devant nous devant nous
français dans tous ceux qui résident en
france également parce que c'est une
sorte de coup de tonnerre le fait que
marine le pen ait dépassé ses 40% et que
avec les élections législatives qui
arrivait comme vous venez de le rappeler
thibault le fait que jean luc mélenchon
a immédiatement le second tour terminé
diffusé enfin le premier venu dévoiler
des affiches disant jean-luc elysées
jean luc mélenchon premier ministre la
situation politique n'est pas du tout
stabiliser je salue tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent sur les différents chat vous
nous posez vos questions mafalda sur
lefigaro.fr qui demandait ce que les
anciens présents seront là oui oui ils
sont là vous avez même françois hollande
à l'image et je pense que juste à côté
de lui c'est nicolas sarkozy on n'a pas
encore tout à fait vu l'image de
l'ancien président de la république
alors il ya des choses qu'on ne verra
pas aujourd'hui alors qu'on voit
jacqueline gourault présente du conseil
du conseil constitutionnel c'est ça non
du fait que nous devrons va vérifier à
son poste
on verra tout au long de cette cette
cérémonie les différentes arrivées en
voit ici richard ferrand avec brigitte
macron notamment benoît puga laurent
fabius ces gens qui sont très importants
dans ce protocole on voit aussi jean
castex juste derrière gérard larcher le
président du sénat ce qui veut dire qu
emmanuel macron ne va pas tarder à
arriver il ya des choses qu'on ne verra
pas aujourd'hui puisqu'il n'ya pas de
passation de pouvoir d'habitude il ya un
rassemblement entre les deux anciens
présidents fin le l'ancien président
sortant et le nouveau là ça ça n'existe
pas oui d'habitude il ya toujours une
conversation
il s'éclipse et parfois ça dure une demi
heure parfois ça dure plus d'une heure
et puis on ne saura jamais ce qu'ils se
sont dit tous les deux sauf si l'un
d'entre eux choisi d'en parler ensuite
et ça ça reste une sorte de mystère
républicain intéressant ou s'il ya
peut-être un moment assez finalement
assez monarchique mais quand on passe le
pouvoir de cette façon c'est au fond
aussi à ces républicains est toute la
question que évidemment on se pose on
aimerait être dans un trou de souris c
est ce que c'est d'une conversation
personnelle d'homme à homme y a pas
encore eu de femme présidente de la
république
de personne à personne ou est-ce que ce
soit c'est une conversation très
attentionné on donne les codes
nucléaires on a cette anecdote qu'on
répète souvent si vous la connaissez pas
de nid terran qui avait perdu les codes
nucléaires qui sont transmis sur une
chaîne en or c'est ce à l effigie du
général de gaulle d'ailleurs et françois
mitterrand avait mis cette petite
chaînette en or dans son savès le soir
ils donnent la veste aux teintures il se
rend compte que la chaîne ait toujours
deux dans les codes nucléaires ont pu
être rattrapé in extremis je précise
quand même puisque j'ai fait une petite
heure jacqueline goémon n'aurions pensé
constitutionnelle et non pas présidente
vous avez vu arriver les personnalités
les plus importantes de l'état avant
cette investiture emmanuel macron qui
doit arriver à 11 heures il est 11
heures une emmanuel macron à contretemps
c'est le nom de votre domicile ça y est
il est déjà à contretemps le maître des
horloges alors que peut-être une arrivée
on voit des militaires qui arrive mais
on va suivre tout ça évidemment j'ai
d'autres j'ai d'autres questions en
attendant et puis je vous couperait
ainsi le président de la république veut
y arriver il est là allez je vous
propose qu'on écoute ce qui ce fait il
doit arriver avec avec de la musique
notamment
[Musique]
il
à
e
[Musique]
monsieur le président la république
le dimanche 24 avril 2022 au second tour
de l'élection présidentielle
nous avait recueilli 18 millions
et
c'est à dire
la majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
dès lors le conseil constitionnel
en navigation des français 58 points en
dha de 5 ans
qui commence samedi prochain 14 mai à 0
au nom du conseil constitutionnel je
vous exprime toutes mes félicitations
du président la république il y a cinq
ans de cela dans cette même salle
à l'occasion de votre première investi
j'avais cité chateaubriand pour être
l'homme de son pays il faut être l'homme
de son temps
or le temps de votre premier mandat
a été notamment percuté par une
accumulation de
crise et de bouleversements sur le plan
sanitaire
sécuritaire sociale énergétique
financiers dont les conséquences ne sont
pas toutes terminées avec notamment un
certain
malaise démocratique préoccupant
c'est pourquoi alors et de votre second
mandat
jeu complet très volontiers
les mots de châteaubriant par ces mots
si de victor hugo
en ces temps troublés
soyons les serviteurs du droit et les
esclaves du devoir
servir le droit c'est d'abord évidemment
respecter l'état de droit
ce patrimoine précieux de principes
essentiels à nos démocraties et à notre
république y compris
si la constitution elle même devait être
révisé c'est en effet la garantie de nos
droits et de nos libertés le devoir
c'est pour chacun sa mesure de
contribuer à relever les grands défis
qui sont ceux d'une nation indépendante
et influente
à commencer par trois d'entre eux le
défi de la paix ou de la guerre
réimposer d'une façon criminelle sur
notre continent européen
77 ans après le 1er et 8 mai
le défi de la lutte
absolument urgente contre le
réchauffement climatique et tour la
préservation de la biodiversité est le
défi du renforcement de la démocratie et
de sa compagne la justice sociale à la
fois en métropole et outre-mer sur le
président relever ces défis nombreux et
difficiles sous votre autorité
sous la conduite du gouvernement
et sous le contrôle du parlement
télé en cette cérémonie de ré
investiture républicaine
le souhait ardent que je porte pour
votre mandat pour les français et pour
la france
monsieur le président de la république
nous vous reconnaissons comme grand
maître de l'ordre national de la légion
d'honneur
le maillon de votre second mandat est
ici ses connaissances du monde avec une
mappemonde et un livre
précédent c'était commerce et
l'industrie
en prix
propose de signer
alors que le président de la république
signe le procès-verbal d'investiture
j'ai toujours avec lucile schmid on suit
évidemment cette investiture sai
emmanuel macron est officiellement réélu
président de la république on va
analyser ce qui vient de se passer on a
entendu parler des maillots on
développera tout ça mon écoute le
président pour son premier discours
mesdames et messieurs
à l'heure où les français me confie à
nouveau la plus haute charge
la conscience de la gravité des temps ma
compagne
et du retour de la guerre en europe à la
pandémie en passant par l'urgence
écologique est temps de crise que vous
venez résidant à l'instant d'évoquer
rarement
notre monde et notre pays n'avait été
confrontée à une telle conjonction de
défis
là où de nombreux peuples ont décidé le
repli
céder parfois à la tentation
nationaliste
à la nostalgie du passé aux sirènes
d'idéologie dont nous pensions avoir
quitté les rives au siècle précédent le
peuple français
a fait le choix d'un projet clair et
explicite d'avenir
un projet républicain et européens un
projet d'indépendance dans un monde
déstabilisé
un projet de progrès scientifique social
et écologique un projet fidèle à
l'esprit qui depuis les lumières n'a
cessé de souffler sur nos terres
tournant le dos aux démagogie facile
ce choix s'inscrit dans l'histoire de
notre république
et la présence ici de mes deux
prédécesseurs que je remercie pour cela
en témoigne
ce choix souverain m'oblige
car c'est bien le peuple français celui
qui désigne ses représentants et en
particulier le président de la
république kim un v6 de ce mandat en ce
jour oui
le peuple français n'a pas prolongé le
mandat qui s'achève commencé le 14 mai
1017 ce peuple nouveau différent d'il ya
cinq ans a confié un président nouveau
un mandat nouveau
le temps qui s'ouvre sera celui d'une
action résolue pour la france et pour
l'europe
agir d'abord pour éviter toute escalade
suite à l'agression russe en ukraine
aider la démocratie et le courage à
l'emporter bâtir une nouvelle peu
européenne et une nouvelle autonomie sur
notre continent agir pour faire de notre
pays une puissance agricole industriel
scientifique et créative plus forte en
simplifiant nos règles et en
investissant pour cette france de 2030
agir pour bâtir une société du plein
emploi et d'un juste partage de la
valeur ajoutée car la france a besoin de
continuer de produire et d'innover
davantage
agir pour faire de notre pays la grande
puissance écologique qu'il a à être par
une transformation radicale de nos
moyens de produire nous déplacer de
vivre en métropole comme dans nos autres
maires
agir pour continuer de nous attaquer aux
inégalités à la racine en refondant
notre école et notre santé
une école toujours plus inclusive
formant aux savoirs fondamentaux et
forgeant d esprit républicain
une école ouvrante à la culture et au
sport nous qui aurons à accueillir les
jeux olympiques en 2024
une santé accessible partout sur le
territoire en forme en améliorant les
conditions de travail et en prévenant
mieux les maladies
agir pour continuer de construire des
progrès pour chacun et uvrer à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
agir pour continuer de protéger nos
compatriotes
par une armée forte engagée sur tous les
continents
et en luttant contre les insécurités du
quotidien du terrorisme qui rôde
toujours et des nouvelles menaces comme
le cyber agir enfin pour réunir
rassembler nos territoires des ruralités
au quartier populaire des métropoles à
nos autres maires oui
agir sans relâche
avec un cap
celui d'être une nation plus
indépendante de vivre mieux et de
construire nos réponses françaises et
européennes aux défis de notre siècle
cette action nous le savons tous ce
inscrits à un moment de la vie de notre
nation où les peurs sont là nombreuses
autant que les fractures
agir ne signifiera donc pas administrer
le pays
enchaîner des réformes comme on
donnerait des solutions toutes faites à
notre peuple
l'action en sept ans et jumelles du
rassemblement du respect de la
considération de l'association de tous
c'est pourquoi il nous faut tous
ensemble
inventé une méthode nouvelle loin des
rites ses chorégraphies usé par laquelle
nous pourrons seul bâtir un nouveau
contrat productif sociale et écologique
car rassemblé pacifié ne saurait
signifier
accepté de ne plus rien faire
oublier nos responsabilités
en partageant les objectifs les
ambitions et les responsabilités au
niveau national en faisant travailler
ensemble gouvernement son administration
le parlement les partenaires sociaux les
associations et en associant partout à
travers le pays l'ensemble des forces
vives politique économique sociale et
culturelle pour décider et faire
en planifiant en réformant en associant
je suis sûr que notre pays
peut
en même temps
décidez de grandes ambitions nationales
et libérer la créativité et les
initiatives partout dans le pays
surtout ce sera là le fondement de la
renaissance démocratique
dans notre pays a besoin
elle sera bien entendu aussi
institutionnels et politiques mais elle
doit être en actes et dans la pratique
de chaque jour et chacun il y aura sa
part de responsabilité
mesdames et messieurs notre passé en est
l'ardent témoignages
c'est dans les temps les plus difficiles
que la france révèle le meilleur
d'elle-même
c'est lorsque se lève le vent du
tragique que nous français
trouvons la force de nous hisser au delà
de nous mêmes pour écrire l'histoire à
lancre de l'universel nous en sommes là
à ce moment où le siècle bascule et ou
dans le grand dérèglement planétaire
nous avons ensemble à tracer un chemin
et a montré une voix
ma conviction est faite
ayons le courage de regarder le réel en
face pour mieux concrétiser notre idéal
plutôt que de nous laisser aller à
d'illusoires chimère soyons fidèles aux
valeurs de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité de laïcité qui nous font
depuis 1789 et que nous avons
collectivement choisi le 24 avril
chérissons en bloc cette histoire
millénaire qui nous lie les uns aux
autres cette culture à part cette langue
dont l'abbé grégoire disait qu'elle est
l'idiome de l'universel
continuons d mais la république et tout
ce qu'elle emporte la prééminence de la
volonté générale sur les intérêts
particuliers
la reconnaissance du verdict des urnes
le respect de la loi comme clé de voûte
du contrat social
est mon
notre patrie comme ce trésor de
géographie de paysages où depuis le
plateau de gergovie jusqu'aux confins
des marquises depuis les pyrénées de mon
enfance jusqu'à mes pleines picarde on
sent battre le coeur de ce vieux peuples
enracinés
qui a offert au monde les rêves les plus
fous
l'humanisme les lumières les droits de
l'homme
alors oui
la france n'aura pas fini d'inspirer le
monde
de la confiance accordée par le peuple
français
je me sers redevable
cette confiance toujours fragile chaque
matin remise en cause est le socle de
notre régime de liberté
chaque jour du mandat qui s'ouvre je
n'aurais qu'une boussole
servir
servir notre pays
miracle de la volonté de la liberté des
hommes
servir nos concitoyens dont le sens du
devoir et l'amour de la patrie sont nos
plus sûrs atouts
servir nos enfants et notre jeunesse
vers lesquels mes pensées vont en cet
instant
et à qui je fais le serment de léguer
une planète plus vivable
et une france plus vivante et plus forte
vive la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà pour ce premier discours officiel
en tant que président de la république
pour un second quinquennat d' emmanuel
macron on va détailler tout ce qu'on
voit tout ce qui s'est passé mais lucile
un premier point sur ceux sur ce
discours plus symbolique que concret
mais l'exercice de ça ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que on l'a esquissé
tout à l'heure laurent fabius a en
quelque sorte récidiver par rapport à
2010 est en prenant 100 avant
qu'emmanuel macron prenant son discours
de président de la république un
discours politique alors que on le sait
le président du conseil constitionnel a
plutôt vocation à priori a présenté des
résultats d'une manière j'allais dire
précise comme un comptable donc le fait
qu'il est associé cette fois ci
chateaubriand dont il avait parlé en
2017 à victor hugo est assez
intéressante et emmanuel macron a
répondu à laurent fabius s'est prononcé
son premier discours de deuxième
quinquennat avec des accents je ne sais
pas s'ils sont symboliques mais ils sont
en tout cas relativement lyrique
littéraire et on sent cette veine
littéraire du président de la république
qu'on connaît on se rappelle comment il
avait été sur france culture parler de
cela de son goût de stendhal leçon pour
la littérature là on sent une certaine
gravité aussi et moi ce qui m'a marqué
c'est le fait qu'ils disent que c'est
est un peuple nouveau qui l'avaient élu
et qu'il serait un président nouveau
c'est à dire qu'il a refusé l'idée d'une
continuité morne entre les deux
quinquennats est proposée face aux
nouveaux défis du monde dont laurent
fabius les a rappelés c'est à dire cette
espèce de contretemps pandémique 7
contretemps sociaux qui sont venus
bouleverser le premier quinquennat des
malades qu'on est au fond il a promis
d'y répondre il a promis de faire
quelque chose qui n'était pas prévisible
vous continuez à réagir nous poser
toutes vos questions mais on essaie
d'expliquer ce qui se passe alors là le
discours vient d'être fait il y a comme
à chaque fois et bien cette petite
déambulation vous voyez on va saluer
tous les tous les invités présents alors
ça c'est là c'est habituel 1 c'est une
présentation des invités par le chef du
protocole on se souvient notamment de
ségolène royal qui en 1988 avait
interpellé françois mitterrand pour lui
demander une circonscription au dernier
moment ça c'était un moment assez fort
je vous propose qu'on jette une oreille
qu'on écoute un peu ce qui se dit le
président de la république qui
s'approche des deux anciens présidents
paris
ah c'était c'était sûr tiff on n'a pas
tout entendu mais je suis sûr que
inquiétez pas sur le figaro là et je
sais qu'il y en a qui travaillent on va
décortiquer sortir cette vidéo et mettre
les sous titres pour voir ce qu'ils se
sont dit alors qu'il brigitte macron
qu'on sait proche de nicolas sarkozy
vient de vient de le saluer alors on a
vu avant lui s'il le général benoît puga
qui a donc remis le collier de la légion
d'honneur le général benoît puga qui est
le grand maître de l'ordre national de
la légion d'honneur il y aura ensuite un
salut aux armes et ça c'est important
dans cette dans cette cérémonie c'est le
principal presque je sais pas si c'est
le principal mais on voit que dans la
période actuelle où j'avais un juppé
c'est important parce que alain juppé
soutient emmanuel macron qu'il reprenne
que il est il était le mentor d'edouard
philippe premier premier ministre
d'emmanuel macron qui compte beaucoup
pour les français qui a une cote de
popularité qui reste très importante
dont on dit qu'il pourrait viser 2027 et
qui aujourd'hui est dans une situation
où par rapport à emmanuel macron il ya
une espèce de petite bagarre là sur les
investitures aux législatives donc c'est
important effectivement que alain juppé
soit laïque les juppéiste soit bien bien
représenté sur la question des armes
thibault effectivement c'est c'est
toujours un moment d'abord extrêmement
émouvant et aussi on voit ce caractère
du monarque républicain particulièrement
avec le cérémonial avec la musique avec
le fait d'aller dans les jardins de
l'elysée de voir
vas y à quelque chose de très émouvant
fait dans ce salut aux armées et puis
comme comme ça a été rappelé dans les
discours on est dans un moment de guerre
et de paix et du coup l'importance du
président de la république comme chef
des armées et particulièrement
essentielle me semble-t-il danse dans ce
jour dans ce jour d'aujourd'hui et puis
je crois que le président de la
république rendra aussi hommage au
régiment à ceux qui ont perdu des hommes
à ceux qui ont souffert par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé au mali ce qui s'est
passé et est rappelé que la paix est
aujourd'hui elle est l est
l est pas elle ne va pas de soi dans le
monde pendant un moment où les
institutions internationales sont assez
faibles c'est essentiel vous continuez à
réagir je vous lis on voit des saluts à
différentes personnes on voit françois
patriat là qui parle de 100 blessés lui
avec le duel mc roger karoutchi devant
on l'a vu saluer tout particulièrement
françois bayrou à qui donc on voit on le
voit serrer la main plusieurs personnes
il a enlacé françois bayrou c'est
important un cnc pas anodin françois
bayrou c'est le marche-pied presque le
porteur d' emmanuel macron à l'elysée et
il continue à être avec lui alors que
certains sont partis on pense à gérard
collomb qui était une des personnes très
importantes on s'en souvient à la
première investiture les larmes aux yeux
les relations se sont un peu tendus avec
gérard collomb mais françois bayrou il
est toujours là françois bayrou ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est
quelqu'un d'une certaine manière qui est
qui a du courage politique au sens où
rappelons nous comment d'abord il avait
en 2000 en 2001 2007 1 au moment des
élections nicolas sarkozy on se rappelle
de ségolène royal si on de faire un de
convaincre françois bayrou de la
soutenir c'est que c'est une personne
qui a eu au fond un rôle j'allais dire
de faiseurs de roi important il l'a eu
en 2010 c'est qu'il a fait confiance à
emmanuel macron c'est quelqu'un qui a
assumé aussi d'avoir très peu de députés
pendant toute une période parce qu'ils
avaient été dépouillés justement par la
droite de sa capacité à avoir des
députés et c'est quelqu'un je le
rappelle qu'il ya aussi cette veine
littéraire on se rappelle de lui nous
disant qu'il dès que sur son tracteur il
débite est des vers de virgile alors
regardez beaucoup appris je vous en prie
edouard philippe là aussi c'est très
important et
poignées de main vigoureuse sourire on
écoute essayons d'écouter
on peut découvrir
et pardon pardon lui s'il devait avoir
coupé mes poignées de mains plus
importante que avec d'autres personnes
et c'est pas anodin il ya en ce moment
officiel officieusement des tensions
entre edouard philippe et emmanuel
macron là on est dans le symbole pur et
dur ce que j'aime faire le président
c'est pas anodin du tout oui une poignée
de main ceci dit ne vont pas promesses
n'ont évidemment mais la nuance avec les
autres autorités bien sûr mais on voit
bien que la la la durée de la poignée de
main est importante et je me disais
envoyant par exemple les poignées de
main nicolas sarkozy et françois
hollande il ya la durée et puis à
l'intensité et puis il ya le petit mot
au fond là-dedans il ya il y aura
matière à décryptage sans fin sur qui
est aujourd'hui en cours et c'est un
côté très monarchique et vous parlez de
françois bayrou on note aller sur les
feuilles ce2 qui le président a été le
plus proche pendant ce salon voit un
hidalgo juste là en rouge derrière je
suis pas certain que le salut soit aussi
vigoureux pierre moscovici qui est
présent également dans cette danse est à
cette investiture
d'emmanuel macron alors on récapitule ce
qu'il s'est passé pour l'instant
emmanuel macron est arrivé laurent
fabius a proclamé les résultats ça c'est
officiel benoît puga le général d'armée
grand chancelier de la légion d'honneur
lui a remis le collier alors 16 maillon
sur ce collier et ça c'est pas demain
parce que chaque président à chaque fois
qu'ils étaient lus à son nom sur un
maillot et cette fois alors il ya
différents maillons je vous le voulez
note alors les maîtres les maillons fait
ce sont les les activités de la nation
voulue par par napoléon qui lui est à
l'origine de ceux de cette légion
d'honneur alors cette fois emmanuel
macron a choisi n'y en a plus que tu
n'avais plus que 3-2 disponibles donc ça
veut dire que ce collier servira
jusqu'en 2032 maximum voilà pour toutes
ces informations sur le col et la légion
d'honneur il a choisi activités de la
nation connaissance du monde avec comme
symbole une mappemonde sur un livre ça
c'est important à emmanuel macron
l'europe il a fait de cette campagne il
a fait de l'europe son cheval de
bataille dans cette campagne si je dire
s'il est concentré dessus tout
particulièrement alors qu'on voit ici
avec des sportifs brahim asloum
notamment champions de boxe asséné en
2000 oui c'est très intéressant de ce
choix de connaissance du monde on le
sait bien c'est pas seulement pendant sa
campagne qui menait le maquereau a
choisi de porter l'attention sur
l'europe dès 2017 il avait prononcé son
grand discours de la sorbonne et ensuite
y avait enfin je sais plus si c'était
juste avant ou juste après il est aussi
ce grand discours prononcé à l'acropole
d'athènes qui assistait d'emblée sur le
fait que la souveraineté européenne
était quelque chose de fondamental et à
les renforcer la puissance française
donc ce cette conviction macro nien
qu'il apportait aussi aux élections
européennes de 2019 qui sont les seules
élections sur lesquels il faut le
rappeler la république en marche et est
obtenue pendant ce mandat un bon
résultat juste derrière le rn le
rassemblement national c'est essentiel
et vous le disiez tout à l'heure
thibault le parti du président va a été
renommé en finlande avec des forces et
le col et voilà après voilà il s'appelle
renaissance le nom de
la liste pendant les européennes donc on
voit bien l'articulation
l'interdépendance extrême que emmanuel
macron veut porter sur la puissance de
la france et la puissance européenne
estelle mossely également championne
olympique de boxe à rio qui est présente
avec avec brahim asloum deux boxeurs
dans les sportifs je note aa fait pas
anodin aussi on va voir des symboles
partout l'heure de jeu c'est cérémonie
mme alors donc le président qui n'a pas
porté le collier ça c'est
assez anciens finalement mais ce faste
républicains se disent car un qui ne
voulait plus à ça exactement et il faut
se rappeler de valéry giscard d'estaing
arrivant à pied effectivement à l'elysée
on rentre avec cette pratique d'arriver
en voiture il je rappelle qu'il était
aussi parti à pied sept ans plus tard
dix et sept ans plus tard lorsque
françois mitterrand avait été élu et que
il avait pris un risque puisque certains
sifflets étaient venus perturber ce
départ de valéry giscard d'estaing de
l'elysée se présenter à pied au fond
aujourd'hui on parle tellement de remise
en cause de la place de la voiture ça
c'est intéressant de repenser à ce
qu'avait fait valéry giscard d'estaing
en 1974
on voit ici ses enfants je vous propose
qu'on écoute c'est une volonté d'
emmanuel macron de mettre une classe de
collégiens au premier rang alors que
christian estrosi est juste derrière on
va écouter ce qui se dit
je connais
vous soyez là
c'est un moment républicain
station versé beaucoup
médecin c'est vous qui allez préparer la
suite
la génération de mes bonnes tables
c'est fort très bien
si fier
voici
venir
comment vas tu
la france
stéphane
je viens très fier des 3
combien
à gagner
voilà emmanuel macron avec avec ses
enfants avec donc cette présentation des
invités jean pierre raffarin teint qui
est là aussi également pas vraiment une
surprise non plus la jeunesse il en a
parlé dans ce discours en parlant
d'écologie un laisser une planète
vivable une fois de plus ça c'est un des
créneaux d'emmanuel mâcon c'est un
créneau mais c'est un créneau sur lequel
on sait il ya une forte déception dans
le mandat précédent
puisque même si des choses ont été
tentées je rappelle que edouard philippe
avait annoncé l'abandon du projet
d'aéroport de notre dame des landes qui
a eu la convention citoyenne pour le
climat à chaque fois la déception a
suivi l'expérimentation où l'initiative
et si emmanuel macron investi autant ce
sujet dans le discours il s'est aussi et
je rappelle c'est un discours il a dit
qu'il fallait agir il sait aussi qu'il
est attendu sur un mode d'action qui
pourrait être assez contradictoire avec
les valeurs qui la portait dans son
premier mandat qui sont des valeurs de
production d'innovations technologiques
alors même que l'enjeu écologique oblige
à changer le modèle je vous coupe un
instant je voudrais écouter ce que va
dire manuel macro à manuel valls
à part
marie
ça va secouer
formidable
c'est vrai mais
ça va
très bien lui c'est bien
succès
l'ancien premier ministre présent
évidemment investi par la république en
marche pour les français de l'étranger
en espagne au portugal en andorre et à
monaco ça va pas être facile parce que
le député sortant lui ne veut pas
laisser la place je voulais aussi dire
une chose c'est que le manuel valls
était est à côté de marisol touraine
voilà ans et demi de la santé et qui par
ailleurs
à gabriella talent était l'attaché
parlementaire de marisol touraine il ya
une sorte de filiation le sait entre la
branche dite strauss kahnienne en fait
du parti socialiste et emmanuel macron
alors qu'on va regarder des stars un
françois cluzet guillaume gallienne
notamment il ya aussi des personnalités
à cette cérémonie et je vous laisse et
je vous laisse reprendre sur sur la
branche strauss kahnienne
je reprends à l'or blanc pour dire que
on voit bien que au sein du parti
socialiste ce qui aujourd'hui sont là et
qui peut être espèrent attendent de
faire partie du prochain gouvernement
ça illustre la façon dont la
recomposition politique est toujours en
marche si je puis dire et ça on verra
comment puisque emmanuel macron place
son mandat sous le signe du renouveau on
verra comment le prochain gouvernement
dira quelque chose sur cette continuité
la recomposition politique alors
justement vous parliez tout ces gens qui
attendent peut-être d'être ministre je
lis en hadjila sur lefigaro.fr vous
continuez à réagir que de courtisans me
dit il c'est vrai que c'est une
cérémonie symbolique républicaine
mais ce passage va avec tous ces gens
qui attendent le président de la
république nous parler de monarchie tout
début de ce live on est presque là
dedans oui moi je suis assez frappé
aussi du fait que avant même qu emmanuel
macron le temps de la main certain temps
de la main vers lui et lui dise je suis
fier d'être là ça a été on a entendu ça
notamment christian estrosi l'a dit et
puis d'autres ont entonné je suis fier
d'être là
après ils sont peut-être objectivement
fier d'être là mais c'est vrai que dans
si peu sont en voie là
c'est un moment important
je pense qu'à voilà il peut y avoir le
plaisir de la victoire je rappelle que
le président doit s'adresser à
l'ensemble du peuple y compris ceux qui
n'ont pas voté pour lui ou qui ont voté
pour lui pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite c'est un point important c'est à
dire comment est ce qu'on fait pour
rassembler lorsqu'on a dit qu'on était
au delà de la droite et de la gauche
et lorsque effectivement comme le dit la
personne qui nous qui nous regardent
lorsque le sentiment que ceux qui sont
là sont peut-être là pour quêter une
position est assez frappant à l'écran
alors on résume ce qu'il s'est passé
depuis 11 heures arrivée du président de
la république dans cette salle des fêtes
le général d'armée benoît puga a remis
le collier de la légion d'honneur sans
lui passait autour du cou on sait que la
tradition veut depuis 1974 que ce
collier soi et bien seulement présenté
sur un coussin en velours rouge cela
juste après l'annoncé officielle des
résultats de laurent fabius et puis
emmanuel macron à a prononcé un discours
assez court à moins d'une dizaine de
minutes du symbolique plus que du très
concret évidemment et puis maintenant et
bien le salut à toutes ces personnalités
ses invités des ministres des anciens
présidents on a vu serrer la main à
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy la
suite du programme eh bien il va quitter
la salle des fêtes et se rendre sur la
terrasse du parc pour saluer les armes
et on y reviendra mais pour l'instant
reste sur sur ce salut je vous propose
qu'on écoute un petit peu ce qui se dit
et puis on revient juste après on
continue à analyser cette cérémonie
d'investiture
[Musique]
comment vas tu es président de chance
m
je prends la chance
ça ira
quand à saint fulgence merci à toi c'est
président dont les voeux de succès
rendez-vous à clichy
ouais
j'ai bien savoir
désolé des marteaux
merci comment vas tu
des présidents de départements des mers
alors ça c'est intéressant parce qu'on
sait qu'au début du premier quinquennat
c'était un peu fâché avec les maires
notamment sur des questions de
financement on se souvient de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
là il ya des mères on a vu karl olive
notamment ceux qui l'ont accueilli
pendant la campagne
on revient aux territoires oui ce qui
est intéressant c'est que en 2017
lorsque mais les maquereaux avait été
élu je rappelle qu'il n'avait jamais été
élu auparavant alors qu'il ya dans le
par il y avait dans le parcours
classique l'idée que leurs racines mans
territoriale était quelque chose de
fondamental est d'ailleurs dans son
discours
emmanuel macron a insisté sur le fait
que nous étions nous français un vieux
peuple qu'il y avait une culture
historique qu'il avait une culture
territoriale il a voulu peut-être aussi
en affrontant ce discours de l'identité
française
rappelé en fin ou ou combattre ou se
confronter aux thématiques qui sont
plutôt celles de la droite extrême mais
je crois que vous avez raison changer la
sociologie de ceux qui sont avec lui
c'est important et il l'a fait
d'ailleurs dans cette campagne éclair
qui l'a mené juste avant le premier tour
mais on continue à suivre donc cette
déambulation dans la salle des fêtes de
l'elysée j'ai vu passer un commentaire
alors ça va tellement vite et beaucoup
de monde sur sur youtube qui nous dit ah
on avait espéré changer les institutions
le référendum la vème république passer
à la 6e là on est pas du tout là dedans
évidemment on c'est un hommage à la vème
république
il l'a encore dit dans son discours les
institutions cette république forte ça
c'est important pour emmanuel macron
pour se différencier notamment de ses
deux opposants principaux marine le pen
d'un côté et jean luc mélenchon de
l'autre alors il ya quelque chose qui a
été dit par laurent fabius qui l'avait
déjà dit en 2017 qui est qu'il ya un
équilibre des pouvoirs c'est à dire un
président de la république mais il ya
évidemment un gouvernement et un
parlement est toute la question au delà
de la changement de constitution que je
ne vois pas effectivement se faire dans
ce deuxième quinquennat c'est le sujet
de l'équilibré du pouvoir est-ce que aux
élections législatives qui viennent il y
aura une majorité pour renaissance
puisque c'est ainsi que s'appelle le
nouveau fait le parti le nouveau nom du
parti du président ou est ce qu'il y
aura au contraire une tripartition comme
on dit beaucoup plus de députés pour le
rassemblement national et la gauche
l'espère une dynamique pour à elle à la
faveur de son rassemblement de son
accord électoral et programmatique
ça c'est un point important
et si le parlement n'est pas dominé si
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas dominé
par renaissance ça peut entraîner au
delà du changement constitutionnel une
pratique du pouvoir différentes on verra
ça évidemment dans un peu plus d'un mois
alors que jack lang est présent
également la gauche l'ancien ministre
meetic si je veux dire de la culture de
françois mitterrand en un sondage d'hier
qui apparut pour le figaro doxa sur la
personnalité du du premier ministre que
veulent les français alors je lis un ça
intéresse assez peu les français que ce
soit un homme une femme un jeune un
vieux de gauche de droite ce qu'ils
veulent c'est quelqu'un proche du
terrain un élu local ça ça les intéresse
on y revient à cette question des des
mers alors qu'on écoute quand même ce
qui se dit avec jack lang peut-être
vous présentez dans
quelques jours et des calculs et nous on
fera ça nous vous avez un grand père
formidable parce que
lundi hypothétique non mais moi je suis
là parce que des jeunes comme ça
ses patrons sinon je n'aurais pas le
droit de siéger
c'est moi qui vous remercie
la bannière
merci à toi
si la vérité
[Musique]
elle est à toi
jack lang qui vient de présenter sa
petite fille emmanuel macron qui on
profite en replaçant un petit mot sur
sur la jeunesse oui les territoires les
français veulent un ministre qui vient
des territoires à la jean castex
finalement 1 ça colle bien ou alors je
rappelle à la edouard philippe parce qu'
edouard philippe était maire du havre et
il n'était pas voilà donc il n'était pas
connue des français et il a été
appréciée des français notamment pour
son flegme sa capacité au fond à
incarner une manière d'exercer le
pouvoir différente de celle d' emmanuel
macron toujours à l' attaque toujours à
l'offensive donc ça je trouve que c'est
très intéressant vous avez raison jean
castex via aussi des territoires et son
accent plus rocailleux fait qu'on
l'identifié envie de sauter leur soir et
puis sa manière d'être
alors pour autant est-ce qu'il s'agirait
d'un maire de droite ce qu'il va aller
chercher plus au centre gauche est ce
que la question du nouveau quinquennat
veut dire à coup un coup de barre à
gauche c'est aussi peut-être une bonne
manière d'anticiper sur les élections
législatives en tout cas les choses sont
très ouvertes et ce qui est intéressant
dans ce que vous disiez thibault c'est
le fait que les français s'en fiche que
ce soit un homme une femme ou quelqu'un
de jeune ils veulent une personne une
personnalité et donc ça signifie qu'ils
veulent quelqu'un qui existent vis-à-vis
des manuels macron alors qu'on sait que
le président de la république est aussi
est aussi une personne qui a cette
réputation d'être autoritaire
accepterait-il d'avoir avec lui un
premier ministre qui est une forme
d'indépendance et c'est aussi un sujet
sur le couple président premier ministre
qui s'opposent de toutes façons de très
longue date soit fillon nicolas sarkozy
michel rocard c'est pour ça que dans la
personnalité du premier ministre dans
les premières pistes on entend souvent
qui emmanuel macron voudrait plutôt un
technicien plus qu'une forte
personnalité politique qui pourrait
envisager et avoir des ambitions plus
tard 11h42 nous sommes en direct pour
suivre l'investiture des manuels macron
qui a prononcé son discours qui a signé
le procès verbal qui est acté le début
de son nouveau quinquennat nous sommes
dans la présentation des invités
d'habitude ya le chef du protocole avec
eux avec le présent là ce n'est pas du
tout le cas le prêt qui fait lui-même le
tour des invités je vous montre ce qui
nous attend juste après regardez ça ce
sont des relais dans les jardins de
l'elysée il y aura un salut aux
militaires ça ça va être important et on
va détailler tout ça mais pour l'instant
on reste évidemment dans la salle des
fêtes de l'elysée je vous propose qu'on
écoute à nouveau on se replonge on va à
l'elysée et on écoute présentation des
invités alors ça ce sont peut-être des
personnalités on voit guillaume
gallienne derrière ce sont les invités
personnels du président c'est lui qui a
décidé d inviter on va écouter
[Musique]
c'est
voilà des personnalités du monde du
théâtre du cinéma françois cluzet
notamment guillaume gallienne toujours
avec cette musique de fond de leur
caisse de la chambre de la garde
républicaine voilà c'est ça que vous
entendez je lis sur youtube thomas
garcia qui dit je lui souhaite bon
courage dans la tâche qui l'attend les
cinq années seront difficiles et
j'espère que la chasse sagesse prévaudra
dans l'action publique il faut préciser
que thomas garcin nous dit j'ai voté
pour marine le pen mais je suis
profondément profondément républicain je
reconnais bien sûr la victoire
d'emmanuel macron avec quand même
beaucoup de personnes qui sont un peu
agacé par ce protocole en disant j'ai vu
passer la soupe est bonne oui c'est vrai
qu'il peut y avoir cette notion là ça
peut un peu énervé certaines personnes
qui nous suivent c'est des ans à cette
déambulation avec tous ses ministres
toutes ces personnalités présentes pour
l'investiture des manuels manquerait
alors la suite et bien c'est l'hommage
militaire on passe aux honneurs
militaires dans quelques instants dans
la dans la cour dans le jardin de
l'elysée ce côté militaire frais qu'on y
revienne lucile schmid c'est important
ça ce statut le président de la
république et le chef des armées il est
le chef des armées et nous sommes dans
un moment particulier où ou comme ça a
été rappelé au moment des discours
notamment par laurent fabius il y à la
guerre sur le continent européen
et ce qui est d'ailleurs assez frappant
dans ce moment que nous vivons en cette
pré campagne des législatives c'est que
bruce comment on a l'impression que
cette question de la guerre en ukraine
c'est face aux profits parfois d'accord
politique qui ne regarde pas assez le
reste du monde et du coup c'est vrai que
le fait que le président soit le chef
des armées le fait qu emmanuel macron
est toujours porté dans son premier
mandat la question de la place
internationale de la france et de la
place de la france dans l'europe puisque
la france fait l'europe tout ça prend
une forme particulière je rappelle que
ça ne lui est pas propre que chaque
nouveau président de la république
fait ces gestes de salut aux armées et
que dans les discours des différents
présidents lorsqu on les relit la
question de la place de la france dans
le monde il ya toujours deux choses il
ya au fond réconcilier les français
entre eux quelle que soit au fond celui
pour lequel ils ont voté et puis il ya
la question de la place de la france
dans le monde le fait que la france est
éclair le sens du monde l'universalité
qui a été rappelé d'ailleurs par
emmanuel macron tout à l'heure ça c'est
un point essentiel et vous avez raison
de le rappeler thibault cette deuxième
partie de la cérémonie qui se passe à
l'air libre qui se passe dans les
jardins a une importance symbolique
peut-être plus forte d'ailleurs parce
que y'a pas tout cette espèce de
sentiment qu'on peut avoir lorsqu'on
n'est pas dans la pièce dire mais alors
attends ils sont tous en train de
quémander leurs poignées de main là on
sera face à cette espèce de discipline
militaire
on attend le président on va pas lui
tendre la main on va montrer
l'obéissance à la république et le
dévouement le fait qu'on est prêt à
mourir pour la république est
brusquement la solennité va certainement
reprendre de l'importance alors vous
l'avez dit ce n'est pas propre à
emmanuel macron ça se fait à chaque
cérémonie d'investiture mais quand même
ce que peut décider le président de la
république c est qu elles sont les les
militaires qui sont présents alors
évidemment il ya mme l'armée de terre la
mer l'air la marine mais je note quand
même qu'ici et bien il y à des personnes
qui sont tout particulièrement
symbolique un régiment de forces
spéciales au sahel la légion étrangère
et puis une partie de l'équipage du
monge c'est ce navire qui est basé à
brest et qui est équipé des radars
chargé de en charge de la surveillance
des missiles balistiques et nucléaires
c'est pas anodin avec ce qui se passe en
russie et avec ce défilé militaire
justement qui se prépare lundi en russie
on sent bien qu'il ya une forme de
symbolique ce n'est pas rien ce jour là
vous avez tout à fait raison thibault
évidemment il ya ce défilé militaire en
russie le 9 mais parce que c'est la date
anniversaire de la victoire de l'as la
victoire des alliés au moment de la
seconde guerre mondiale et ça va être
une démonstration de force et de ce fait
aujourd'hui et la façon dont on met en
valeur vous l'avez rappelé certains
régiments au sahel dont durant 15 ans
subit enfin qui ont été leur dévouement
le fait d'accomplir leur devoir ça a été
rappelé tout talent laurent fabius a
parlé du fait qu'il y avait un devoir
aussi dans la lah responsabilités
présidentielles cette question de
remettre au centre du jeu le sujet du
devoir républicain y compris lorsqu'on
choisit de mourir pour la république
c'est un point important pour le
président l'héroïsme de nos troupes et
puis vous vous parliez du nucléaire il
ya il ya plusieurs choses le nucléaire
la france est une force est une
puissance nucléaire militaire et vous le
rappeliez
lorsqu'il n'ya passation des pouvoirs ça
n'a pas été le cas aujourd'hui puisque
emmanuel lacroix et intérêts non ce sont
les codes nucléaires qui sont donnés
lors de l'entretien entre les deux
présidents dont kylie à cette question
du fait que le président de la
république a les codes nucléaires et
puis il y a le fait que la russie
aujourd'hui on se pose sans cesse la
question depuis depuis l'invasion de
l'ukraine est ce que le nucléaire va
être employé qu'est ce qui va se passer
est ce que c'est pas évident non c'est
pas du tout anodin on suit donc cette
cérémonie d'investiture emmanuel macron
qui semble achevé son salut à tous les
invités
450 500 personnes présentes dans cette
salle des fêtes avant de passer aux
hommages militaires vous continuez à
réagir sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube sur
twitch on vous lit on essaie de vous
lire vous êtes très nombreux et en suis
en même temps ce qui se passe depuis
depuis l'elysée je vous donne le
programme quand même parce qu'on a ce
programme qui nous est envoyé par par
l'elysée alors le président de la
république qui va sortir sur la terrasse
du parc désormais guidés par l'aide de
camp le chef de l'état accompagné de
gérard larcher président du sénat
richard ferrand président de l'assemblée
nationale et voyages on y vient à ce
jardin de l'elysée le président de la
république qui se présentent sur la
terrasse et marque un temps d'arrêt
pendant que retentisse 21 coups de canon
tirés depuis l'hôtel des invalides alors
ça c'est issus de l'ancien régime c'est
une tradition quand un roi était dans
les obsèques d'un roi des quais
l'avènement d'un autre on a gardé cette
tradition avant c'était sans un de
gaulle à dinan 101 c'est trop 21 coups
de canon mais quand même mitterrand et
chirac lorsqu'il avait été élu n'avait
pas accepté qu'on tire ses pôtes chalon
depuis les invalides oui donc vous avez
raison niveau là il ya une à fast et le
choix de mettre en avant la dimension
militaire de chef des armées par
emmanuel macron donc ça c'est un point
qui me semble due au contexte
on a ce contexte de guerre en ukraine on
a ce sentiment d'instabilité de menaces
on sait qu'au sahel la menace islamiste
est puissante on sait aussi qu'il ya eu
d'ailleurs des coûts mis des coups
d'état militaires dans un certain nombre
de pays africains ces derniers mois ces
dernières depuis depuis l'année dernière
burkina faso mali donc on est dans une
situation d'instabilité évidemment voilà
je vais tout ce que je viens de vous
expliquer ces maps ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
le président de la république
les honneurs militaires ont été rendus
par un détachement composé
bagad de lann-bihoué
de la musique du drapeau d'une section
du premier régiment d'infanterie de la
garde républicaine
d'éléments du 1er régiment parachutiste
d'infanterie de marine
également la détachement de la légion
étrangère
du commando hubert du bâtiment mange des
forces aériennes spéciale du
commandement de l'espace du commando
parachutiste de l'air numéro 10
l'ensemble est commandée par le colonel
frédéric poulin commandant le 1er
régiment d'infanterie de la garde
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
maintenant avec un infini respect
non mais moi
[Musique]
non pour la france
merci
[Applaudissements]
à
je
m'étais afia beau métier en mer où ça
[Applaudissements]
l'antenne
voilà les 21 coups de canon depuis les
invalides pour saluer le président de la
république qui s'est ensuite rendue
seule au drapeau la marseillaise
entonnée par par la garde républicaine
et puis il a passé en revue les troupes
avec le bagad de lann-bihoué
interprétant entre terre et mer cette
musique que l'on connaît très bien les
troupes présentes elles ont été citées
et puis un salut aux commandants
d'unités en deuil et puis maintenant les
chefs d'état major le premier d'entre
eux le général thierry burkhard de chef
d'état major des armées on écoute on
retourne dans les jardins de l'elysée
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous et
[Applaudissements]
la voiture est interdite merci
formellement à la tradition avec la
batterie d'honneur pour l'école
d'artillerie de draguignan
donc remercier demandait aux invalides
s'est fait virer je vous retrouverez
demain de salim swedan
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà pour cette cérémonie d'investiture
fait toujours avec lucile schmid ça y
est on a fait le tour on va c'était
encore ensemble quelques instants pour
essayer d'analyser de comprendre tout ce
qu'il vient de se passer est justement
sur sur cet hommage aux aux armées
symbole fort on le sait en ce moment
c'est pas anodin du tout du tout non
c'est pas anodin et il ya eu enfin je
trouve que l'émotion que l'on peut
ressentir y compris comme spectateur
dans ce deuxième moment de la cérémonie
est très fort une sorte de contraste par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé les
poignées de mains les volumes attendu
presque comme une sorte de meetings
bourgeois et aristocratique à l'elysée
loin au fond de ce qu'on imagine de la
république pour tous je trouve en
revanche avec les armes et je trouve
qu'on partage quelque chose et que dans
l'espèce de dignité qui fait partie du
cérémonial c'est à dire que ce qui est
frappant c'est que le président de la
république tend la main un certain
nombre de ces dignitaires militaire mais
qu'avant ils font le salut est que voilà
les choses sont codifiés quelque chose
se passe de la vie de la mort de la
capacité à être héroïque pour la
république et je veux que cette deuxième
partie de cérémonie était très réussi
pas de visite à l'hôtel de ville 1
d'habitude c'est ce que font les
présidents la pâte visite on sait c'est
une cérémonie un peu particulière
puisque c'est une reconduction
finalement mais on se passe cette fois
de certains symboles demain c'est lui
mais il faut le préciser aussi mais
pareil aujourd'hui un pas deux pas de
rendez vous sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu on veut pas en faire trop on
veut pas en faire trop et puis sur la
question de l'hôtel de ville jeu on a vu
anne hidalgo arrivé 1 elle était parmi
les invités
avec une veste rouge on l'a vu être au
deuxième rang d'ailleurs elle n'était
pas au premier rang dans les invités
je ne suis pas sûr que le président de
la république je vais serrer la main
mais en tout cas elle était présente et
on sait que lorsque le président
commence un deuxième mandat d'une
certaine manière la cérémonie est par
nature plus sobre dans le contexte
actuel où comme on l'a rappelé marine le
pen a fait un score très élevé où on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer aux
législatives la question la sobriété
pour montrer le passage à l'action
rapide était aussi me semble-t-il un
symbole fort pour emmanuel macron voilà
on revoit ses images qui vous ont
particulièrement marqué plus que là la
première partie sur sur les armes et la
suite du programme pour emmanuel macron
il faut trouver un gouvernement
maintenant il faut trouver un
gouvernement il faut commencer par
trouver un premier ministre là toute la
semaine les rumeurs ont
bruissé qu'il aurait proposé les choses
à deux femmes dites de gauche entre la
présidente du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée valérie rabault et et
véronique b d'agde qui avait été
directrice de cabinet de manuel valls
lorsqu'il était premier ministre
dans les deux cas elles ont tenu à faire
savoir qu'elle avait refusé on sait
qu'être premier ministre avant les
élections législatives
c'est être en transition parce que tout
dépend de la façon dont les élections
législatives vont se passer on avait
évoqué
elisabeth bornes qui était au premier
rang un ministre comme qui viennent elle
était là il avait très très en avant au
premier rang
ministre de l'emploi voilà est-ce que en
tout cas il ya certainement maintenant
une certaine urgence à ce que emmanuel
macron annonce
annonce le nom de ceux de ce ou de cette
première ministre même si je crois que
le porte parole du gouvernement a
insisté gabriela talent sur le fait que
voilà il fallait prendre aussi son temps
et que personne n'impose rey à emmanuel
macron un rythme cette cérémonie qui a
duré une heure tout rond 1 c'est plus
que mitterrand et chirac qui avait fait
plus court moins d'une demi heure chacun
un quart d'heure 25 minutes pour pour
les deux on a quand même voulu du côté
de l'elysée garder ce cérémonial est
d'autant que le contexte de guerre bien
pousse peut-être le président à a montré
un set son rapport à l'armée et son
importance qu'il donne à l'armée dans
cette situation et puis vous savez je
crois que les français
moi je dois dire que je suis attachée à
une forme de formalisme institutionnel
qui montre aussi l'importance de la
fonction et de ce que nous partageons
c'est à dire que dans un moment où
emmanuel macron a été réélu on se
rappelle que dans le débat de second
tour il était comme ça en avant très
offensif là il ya une espèce de dignité
de la fonction au delà de la personne
qu'il me semblait important de
d'incarner et puis il ya eu ce discours
de laurent fabius président du conseil
constitutionnel il a eu la présence de
françois hollande et de nicolas sarkozy
pour rappeler que les institutions ce
n'est pas une seule personne c'est aussi
la permanence et la continuité de la
république mais vous n'êtes pas la seule
lucie la avoir été particulièrement
touché par cette deuxième partie de
cérémonie dans les jardins de l'elysée
avec les militaires christian les ont
tous un très fort son mot et sans voix
voilà ce qu'il nous dit on va approcher
à la fin de ce live puisque cette
cérémonie est finie on débrief quand
même un petit peu ce qu'on a vu je
voudrais vous raconter cette histoire
parce qu'il n'ya pas de passation mais
si vous connaissez l'histoire des trois
enveloppes ce que vous connaissez sur sa
campagne par exemple parce que
d'habitude dès qu'il ya une passation de
pouvoir les deux présidents le sortant
et l'entrant se réunissent ça peut durer
20 minutes si c'est un peu tendu plus
longtemps est une légende dit que chaque
président transmet trois lettres à son
successeur alors les trois mêmes qu'il a
reçu de son prédécesseur le nouveau
président a pour consigne de n'ouvrir la
première lettre qu au bout de quelques
mois lorsqu'il devient impopulaire dans
cette première lettre est notée mettez
tout le dos tout sur le dos de votre
prédécesseur ce jeudi la première
missive puis quelques mois plus tard
quand la situation s'est encore dégradée
deuxième lettre à ouvrir blâmer la
conjecture dit que vous avez pris la
mesure de la situation et annoncé un
complet remaniement ministériel
voilà ce que doit faire de la consigne
de la deuxième enveloppe et puis malgré
le répit quand l'un popularité remonte
il faut ouvrir la troisième lettre où il
est écrit préparez vos trois enveloppes
voilà donc on comprend bien que c'est
difficile ce poste de président de la
république il va avoir 50 difficile à
nouveau emmanuel macron wii est
certainement et puis comme dans
l'anecdote que vous citez il pourra pas
dire mettez tout sur le compte de votre
prédécesseur nord que c'était bien plus
qu'elle maintenait que mais il nous a
quand même dit dans son discours et
c'est quelque chose que je retiens c'est
que ce serait un nouveau mandat que
c'était un peuple nouveau qu'il avait
été lui et qu'il serait un nouvel
emmanuel macron qu'est ce que ça
signifie c'est encore mystérieux mais en
tout cas la question d'introduire une
forme de rupture entre le premier et le
deuxième quinquennat a été posée
d'emblée par emmanuel macron voilà ce
qu'on pouvait dire sur cette cérémonie
d'investiture je vous donne quand même
la suite du programme pour emmanuel
macron et du foot ce soir finale de la
coupe de france il y sera le président
c'est aussi une tradition on sait qu'ils
saluent les deux équipes avant le avant
le coup d'envoi les commémorations du 8
mai demain où il fleurira la tombe du
soldat inconnu puisqu'il n'a pas fait
aujourd'hui ce qui est fait
habituellement lors dès lors des
cérémonies d'investiture
et puis lundi 9 mai important
défilé militaire en russie en suivra ça
c'est aussi pour ça que le président
voulait cette date avant se décider du 9
mai au cas où le président poutine
annoncé
peut-être une invasion plus importante
en ukraine discours à strasbourg en tant
que président de l'europe c'est vrai un
tweeter présidence de la france de
l'union européenne près discours à
strasbourg au parlement européen et puis
direction berlin premier déplacement
officiel chez olaf 'les ça c'est très
important parce que ce couple franco
allemand comment est-ce qu'il va se
réorganiser il n'ya plus angela merkel
qui a toujours soutenu emmanuel macron
avec laquelle il y avait une vraie
capacité à avoir un projet stratégique
européen et olaf scholz on le sait est à
la tête d'une
coalition tripartite ce n'est pas si
simple pour la chose que ce l'était pour
angela merkel merci d'avoir suivi avec
moi cet événement lucille schnee que je
rappelle votre votre livre il est ici le
montre up emmanuel macron à contretemps
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire par un
par là à une union mâcon à contretemps
alors moi je ce que je veux dire avec
mon co auteur olivier mongin c'est que
emmanuel macron appris à contretemps la
vie politique française lorsqu'il a
gagné en 2007 en promettant d'ailleurs
un renouvellement complet qu'il a été
pris aussi à contretemps pendant son
mandat par le cours du monde avec la
pandémie avec la guerre en ukraine et
que cette question du contretemps qui
peut être fécond pourquoi pas déranger
et disrupt et comme il aime le dire il
doit aussi maintenant recréer un nouvel
espace temps démocratique en sortant du
contretemps par rapport à la société
française on retrouve en en réconciliant
au fond ce qu'il est la société
française l'audace et la continuité
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cet événement
avec nous le programme figaro lie ces
danses ce week-end cet après-midi en
laye le pur-sang commentaires comme ça
vous pouvez encore mieux apprécier
l'événement vous suivez le rassemblement
de la gauche évidemment la première
image avec l'accord de l'union entre
tous les partis jean luc mélenchon sera
là fabien roussel olivier faure julien
bayou ensemble aux docks d'aubervilliers
cesser cet après-midi et puis demain
même format les commémorations du 8 mai
avec emmanuel macron qui se rendra donc
sur la tombe du soldat inconnu notamment
encore merci lucile schmid d'avoir été
avec moi vous revenez quand vous voulez
pour suivre ces événements c'est l'adn
de fear alive de pouvoir suivre et vous
expliquez vous raconter ces événements
merci à tous de nous avoir écrit vous
étiez très nombreux à nous laisser des
messages on a essayé de vous lire au
maximum vous ne ratez rien vous le savez
vous restez avec nous à bientôt sur
figaro live merci